if we look through different lists of
the biggest religions in the world
hinduism is often at somewhere at the
top of that list it is often ranked as
the
third or fourth largest religion in the
world with an enormous following of over
1 billion people in this series of
videos i want to explore the vast
religion of hinduism as well as other
religions with origins in the indian
subcontinent which are often known as
the dharmic religions but i will have a
bit of a different approach to this i
will not be asking questions like what
is hinduism as that would be plagued
with a lot of problems what we call
hinduism is such a vast and broad term
that it's questionable if it can even be
called a religion at all
it should really properly be seen as an
umbrella term for a vast amount of
different religious traditions from
india
which can sometimes be drastically
different from each other now much of
this can of course be said about other
religions too christianity is also an
umbrella term of sorts for a vast amount
of different traditions as is islam
but when it comes to hinduism this is
true to an unusual degree some even want
to say that hinduism is actually many
different religions altogether that is
only artificially
sort of unified into a single whole and
while this may be a question of
semantics i generally don't like to go
this far sure hinduism is a very
slippery term that denotes many
different sometimes very loosely
connected religious traditions in india
but they all have certain
characteristics or core features that
unify them and which also separates them
from other religions in the region like
buddhism or jainism and the primary
unifying characteristic of this vast
category called hinduism what ties it
all together you could say is its bases
in and relationship to the scriptures
known as the vedas
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so in this series i will not be asking
questions like what is hinduism as i
said but instead i will be focusing on
specific subjects particular subjects
that will serve as representations of
this vast religion so that includes the
different scriptures different great
theologians and philosophers as well as
how hinduism functions as a living
religion both historically and today and
what better place to start than with the
foundational and most important sacred
scriptures in hinduism the vedas now
hinduism is sometimes called the oldest
still existing religion in the world and
this is somewhat of an
oversimplification since many of the
core features that we recognize as
hinduism appears quite late in history
in a few centuries into the common era
but at the same time some of the
foundations of what we call hinduism
date back very far back in history
indeed the earliest veda scriptures are
some of the oldest surviving religious
literature in all of history while they
weren't written down until much later it
is said that the earliest
parts of the vedas were written sometime
around 1500 bce the vedas are considered
revealed scripture called shruti in
sanskrit in other words they were not
written by human hands but revealed
directly by the gods to the ancient
sages who then memorized them
these sages and quote-unquote authors of
the vedas are called rishis and the
revelations that these rishis received
are all in the language called sanskrit
which is a language that belongs to the
larger indo-iranian and indo-european
language group the origins of this
culture and its textual tradition is
somewhat shrouded in mystery and there
are many different theories
generally it is thought that the vedic
culture as it has become known
immigrated into this indian subcontinent
during the second millennium bce from
west from the west and is part of the
ethnic group known as the aryans
it was thus not native to india but came
from further west and shares cultural
and religious origins with the people of
what is today iran and with the greater
persian region
although this can be quite a
controversial subject for some and as i
said much of this is quite uncertain
still what is clear is that the earliest
veda text appeared in a religious
context in northern india accompanied
with certain ritual traditions that
involved a ritual sacrifice the vedas
can be quite complicated in their
structure and and on different parts but
generally they are divided into four
categories the rig veda the sama veda
the yayurveda and the afar veda the
earliest of these is the rigveda
composed as early as around 1500 bce
the others were written during the
following centuries being composed
somewhere between 1200 to 800 bce the
vedas were originally oral traditions
and were not written down until later
so if we take the oldest for example the
rigveda the hymns and mantras that it
contains were orally transmitted between
masters and students with
minute detail both the words and sounds
but also specific melodies and
pronunciations
this tradition even continues to this
day so that when you listen to priests
reciting the vedas today you are
listening to the exact way that they
would have sounded thousands of years
ago
to quote michael with cell it's called
something like a tape recording of circa
1500 to 500 bce
the main parts of these four veda
collections are consists of hymns to the
gods and mantras to be recited while
performing the ritual sacrifice
the vedic culture and religion that had
emerged at this time was a highly
ritualized religion in which a class of
priests called the brahmanas would
perform various rites one of the central
rituals and one that is mentioned a lot
in the vedas is the soma ritual
soma was a drink that was consumed and
so naturally a lot of
speculation has gone into figuring out
what this drink actually was and or
consisted of we don't actually know for
sure
naturally of course many people have
speculated that it may have contained
certain psychedelic compounds and that
maybe the rishis who composed the vedas
did so under the influence of this soma
drink another very important ritual at
this time was the shrouta which involved
a ritual fire
in this ritual the priests would offer
different objects like food and drink to
the gods by throwing them into the fire
while reciting certain mantras and
prayers
this fire throwing this fire sacrifice
or fire offering was the main ritual in
all of the early vedic religion and was
central to the worldview and the order
of the universe for the vedic people
generally
the ritual sacrifice and the offerings
functioned as a kind of exchange
the gods were given gifts and in return
human beings received blessings of
different sorts and this exchange
between the human and divine world is
what kept the universe a society and
nature in its proper order so all of
these vedas are deeply interconnected
with the ritual practices of the brahman
religion they are the contents of and
you can say guidebooks for how to
perform these vedic rites and the hymns
that these vedas contain give us some
loose idea of what the theology of the
time looked like there are certain gods
that are especially prominent like agni
the god of fire and indra among many
others but the specifics of how these
gods functioned as a difficult question
to answer
there are clearly many different gods
mentioned in the vedas which indicates a
polytheistic religion but we also find
statements like the following in the rig
veda quote god is one men call him by
various names which seems to indicate a
theology where there is one god in
reality and the other gods mentioned are
only different names or aspects of this
god and this does seem to predict
certain later developments in hinduism
some deities in the hymns seem to be
personifications of things like natural
phenomena but not all of them are some
of the gods probably were
old kings or human beings that were
deified after death which was a very
common practice for ancient polytheistic
religions but we're gonna make things
even more complicated so these four
vedas the rigveda the sama veda the
yayoid veda and the arthur veda are also
divided into different sections so
number one is the samhitas which this is
the part that we discussed so far this
is the oldest and main part of the vedas
the hymns and mantras to the gods this
is what we've been talking about
sometimes when we talk about the vedas
in a more narrow sense it is simply only
referring to the samhitas so this is
really the the central the main part of
the vedic corpus but
usually when we say the vedas we're
talking about a larger collection of
texts than simply these samhitas and
this includes these other categories
which includes number two the brahmanas
which are commentaries that try to
explain and contextualize the deeper
meanings of the vedic rituals there is
the aranyakas which discuss the ritual
sacrifice and its deeper meanings as
well and lastly there are the upanishads
which is quite different from the rest
the upanishads are philosophical texts
that discuss various aspects of life and
death the soul
meditation and much much else so to make
things extra clear each of the four
vedas has all of these four sections or
layers to them the last part of the
vedas the upanishads are especially
fascinating in this context and would
come to play a very significant and
important role in the later development
of what we recognize as hinduism today
whereas the other parts of the vedas are
usually only
really interested in
the the rituals the vedic rituals and
their meaning
the upanishads are highly speculative
philosophical and they introduce many
new concepts and ideas that are not
present or just doesn't seem to be
present at least in the other parts of
the vedas the upanishads are also
sometimes referred to as vedanta which
literally means the end of the vedas
because it is literally
the end of the vedas both in the sense
of being the last part of the vedas that
was written but also functions as the
last section of the vedas written
sometime in the middle of the 1st
millennium bce the upanishads continue
the
speculation and tradition of the
brahmana texts by trying to find the
deeper meanings of the vedic rituals but
it probably also has origins outside of
this ritual culture
primarily in the northeastern part of
india there had appeared what is known
as the shramana movement
there is some disagreement on whether
this was a part of the vedic religion
that grew out of this already existing
vedic tradition or if it was an
independent movement altogether
in any case the sramana movement was
characterized by individuals living
ascetic lives trying to find
enlightenment or liberation through
turning inward
so instead of the vedic focus on
external ritual and the centrality of
the sacrifice for upholding the universe
the shraman ascetics looked within
themselves to find the answers and
indeed it seems like it was with the
sramana movement that some of the more
characteristic aspects of the dharmic
religions originated ideas like karma
and samsara that is ideas about
reincarnation and that are actions not
just the ritual sacrifice but all our
actions determine the nature of that
reincarnation
there is also
among these
mystics there was the idea of moksha or
liberation the idea that the goal of
life should be to end this cycle of
rebirths and to be liberated from them
altogether and this does not seem to
have been present as an idea in the
earlier vedic religion for those
scholars who argue that the sramana
movement was something separated from
the vedic religion originally
they argued that it was as a result of
the meeting of the vedic ritualized
religion and the surah movement that
produced the upanishads this kind of
synthesis between these two religious
traditions the upanishads in fact seem
to take ideas and concepts and themes
from the earlier veda scriptures and
give them a new philosophical meaning
inspired by the ideas of the sramana
movement but others interpret them not
as new meanings but
simply as deeper meanings or
understandings of the already existing
vedic concepts so there's a bit of
disagreement here as well for example
the concept of brahman which had
previously signified the power of the
ritual sacrifice and its ability to
uphold the world became a central theme
in the upanishads and was extended even
further to mean the very foundation and
ground of existence and the universe
everything comes from the brahmana
everything returns to the brahman and
according to some interpretation
everything is the brahman another very
important theme that appears in the
upanishads is the idea of the atman or
the transcendent self which seems in
some way to be
connected to part of or even identical
with the brahman and many different
traditions and interpretations of these
upanishads appeared over the coming
centuries which have together often come
to be known as vedanta
so and this can look very different so
for example
the scholar adi shankara
interpreted the upanishads in a very in
a non-dual way
which gave rise to the school known as
advaita vedanta whereas on the other
hand the scholar madhvacharya
interpreted them in a dualistic way and
gave rise to dvita vedanta which is
quite different and we will indeed be
exploring many of these thinkers and
schools in future videos indeed these
sages behind the upanishads can in some
way represent a form or a certain
strand of the suramar movement that
adopted the earlier vedic text as
authoritative scriptures whereas other
sramana movement indeed
religions like buddhism and jainism
actually originated as sramana movements
and and but they can be seen as shramana
ascetics that did not accept the
authority of the vedas the vedas are not
sacred scriptures to either the
buddhists or the jains
so this is a difference between them
there were shaman ascetics who did not
accept the authority of the vedas which
created things like buddhism and jainism
but the
sages that did accept the authority of
the vedas it is they who seem to have
produced the the upanishads and which
also then led to hinduism thus through
the meeting of the sramana movement and
the court tradition of brahmana vedic
ritual religion and their consolidation
in the literature of the upanishads the
vedic religion was fundamentally
transformed ideas like samsara karma and
moksha became central concepts that
would remain cornerstones of all the
traditions the religious traditions in
india that followed in other words
through this last part of the vedas and
their influence we are one step closer
to something resembling hinduism today
to put it simply the vedas are a massive
collection of texts of many different
parts and different kinds of texts and
will take further centuries of an
enormous amount of different
commentaries and interpretations and
schools of thought before we reach
something that resembles hinduism so let
me know in the comments if there's any
other specific topic within this larger
subject of hinduism or the dharmic
religions that you would like me to to
tackle or cover
there's a lot to to go through here of
course and and
i have a lot of things that i want to
talk about of course but i would love to
hear your suggestions as well as always
i want to thank my patreon supporters
who make this channel possible it is
really only through your support that
i'm able to
for example buy books to research these
videos and then for many other things so
it is really you guys who keep this
channel going
so thank you thank you so much as always
of course i would like to also go
through some of the recent arrival to
our patron team i would like to thank
muhammad babiker yasir haan yatshuba
davis ethan ross muhammad and pervez
rasheed thank you all so much for your
support i hope this introduction to the
most sacred scriptures of hinduism
wasn't too complicated it is a difficult
topic of course and a vast one than one
that is shrouded in a lot of mystery and
yet it is one that is very important to
understand hinduism which is after all
one of the largest and most influential
religions in the world
so i'll see you next time
[Music]